Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
I mean that this is classic Stevenson
ladies and gentlemen put the kids to
sleep
hurry defender falls down
that makes it 120 no 119 we are under
three minutes here in the fourth quarter
that was just a fantastic jab step right
there
[Applause]
what a challenge we have
[Applause]
that is the best I've seen really and I
could meet this guy can get any shot he
wants when he wants to get it
[Applause]
somebody give Kent Bazemore of man so he
can locate James Harden
the James is in the lane shooting a
Florida if he can't find him
mid-range shot but drove it
and what a move by common sense from a
bell to the ground hold [ __ ] up
please discuss shake em up get it down
Oh young soul
sorry Bradley
Piper in the building yo you in when the
player stumbles you just got a complete
look at the bits look at the bench that
was a sack and sting it off that rim
[Applause]
Hornswoggle befuddled
scooters in session but don't feel bad
you'll do it again
yes
Reggie Jackson's had a 12-point quarter
and he put miles turns to the floor on
this move the curtains are on a nine to
two run one of these days you go get an
extra point for breaking an angle like
that
[Applause]
do that DJ when to quit college
[Applause]
so push balls getting on the act now
home this is DJ Wilson exit stage left
oh hi salinities chops
[Applause]
Oh
so heartened drains the three and gets
an analyst look at Chris Paul you saw
this one up into boy Adam left coach you
like that content I know you like that
content hit subscribe for more of it
from Bleacher Report